first question is what every American
waking up wants to know how much danger
is the United States in right now well
we're still along that predictable arc
but I think most people have been
watching this problem expected I mean
the timing may have been a bit of a
surprise but the North I believe was
going to do this this is their plan this
is where they were going they're doing
it for their own purposes
I don't mean to criticize the current
administration I think some of the
things they've done to amp up the
pressure on the North Koreans have been
absolutely appropriate but you realize
the sum total after seven months of the
Trump administration is that North Korea
is much further along in its missile and
its nuclear program just the way it
performed when President Obama was
president and President Bush was
president there's a real consistency
here a scary consistency need and you
did tell my colleague Jake Tapper what
you just alluded to there that you
believe they said this on August 9th
that Trump has a coherent plan on North
Korea and it was in artfully executed a
lot has changed since then as you just
mentioned do you still believe the White
House has a reasonable plan to deal with
North Korea I I do know it's still an
artfully executed you got to watch the
tweets and I think we had an unforced
error over the weekend when we brought
up our free trade agreement with our
South Korean friends on whom we rely on
with them we will have to cooperate for
this problem just out of the blue the
president indicated he may want to
renegotiate that agreement I think
that's probably wrong on the merits and
it's certainly not integrated into a
broader approach to Northeast Asia so I
think that hurt so still an artfully
executed but again I think our policy is
to impress upon the Chinese how
seriously we view this North Korea's
been along this predictable arc the
unpredictable actor has been us we've
actually acted with more sound and fury
than I think the Chinese are accustomed
to I think we've done that with purpose
in essence to discomfort the Chinese
with the current situation exactly and
you know in all fairness and I think
this is what you're pointing out with
the part of the Trump policy on North
Korea that you like that everything that
has been tried for the past two decades
has not worked so why not
you know rattle the cages particularly
of the Chinese but it hasn't worked not
not so far and it's not cost-free then I
mean 18 24 months ago I pointed out that
we'd probably be where we are now on
this arc with the North Koreans getting
more capable and more dangerous we would
be there almost certainly within our
current definition of acceptable risk
and clearly what the Trump
administration has decided to do was to
embrace a bit more risk to be a bit more
activist be a bit more destabilizing of
the piece of the stability of the
peninsula not to influence the North
Koreans they're not influenceable but to
influence the Chinese to amp up the
pressure I do think there is an absolute
marked difference between the Chinese
response to intercontinental ballistic
missile tests and a nuclear test I
actually do think that's a bit of a
political redline for the Chinese so
that gives us an opportunity here to try
to cooperate with the Chinese to get the
region to do more okay so President
Trump is gonna meet with his national
security team later today if you were in
that meeting
on that note on China or maybe anything
else you want to share what would you be
arguing for on how to act right now so
first of all the military options are
all bad they're not zero and the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs is pointed
out there they're never no military
options so we've got them but none of
them are good I think diplomatic
isolation check we've got that this may
be the time now to really hammer home
we're deathly serious about your
performance China on sanctions not just
the ones that were recently passed by
the Security Council but maybe even
amping up the sanctions between China
and North Korea North Korea is dependent
on the Chinese for their energy they can
actually pull the string there
and what do you think is the difference
what what makes you think that trying to
do that now with China is going to be
any more successful than it was
yesterday as bad as you and I and the
president view what Kim jong-un did
yesterday with the nuclear test
unbalance I don't think that was aimed
at us I think that was aimed at the
Chinese I think that was little Kim
saying - she's Jinping you can't make me
stop and there I think is a proposition
that Mister she might not be able to
accept you talk about sort of the
erratic policy and some of the tweets do
you have confidence that President Trump
can handle this I have confidence that
he has a very good team that will lay
out very good options I fear two things
number one the stray electron
all right the the tweet it just goes out
at 5:00 a.m. and it unintentionally
creates effects that make this go to a
place we don't want it to go the other
one is this all right we just got into a
duel with the North Korean chairman with
Kim jong-un if we had a choice of
weapons I think it was a bad choice to
get into a high hyperbole contest with
that kind of guy
the only thing I fear mr. president is
not a manhood issue this is a national
security issue don't don't let your
pride get ahead of white wise policy
here that is very sound advice thank you
so much we hope people are watching in
the White House general Hayden thank you
especially for coming in thank you a
short notice with this breaking news
appreciate it